[Applause]
thank you so much
i am a little over cleansed it's our
last show
i will i will uh
i will miss seeing half your faces every
week
and the roar of muffled laughter really
i
i tell you when i get back the only mass
people better be at a eyes wide shut
party okay
but this is when we always take our
break it's thanksgiving thursday are you
excited about room
thanksgiving come on
it's actually a huge anniversary
400 years the first one was 1621. did
you know that
i know why wasn't that a bigger story i
guess
because it's bad now well you know it's
it's commemorating the first time that
the
settlers and the indians shared a meal
of course that's the white version of
the story the
indians remembered at that time that
some undocumented immigrants
arrived uninvited and had anchor babies
that's how they
which is kind of the truth of it
okay all right
we know you're good people who are on
the side of the indians okay
let's just leave that [ __ ] at the door
shall we
speaking of liberals uh
thanksgiving a reminder to all my
liberal friends remember to allow enough
time to thaw out the baby
if you're
because they eat babies according to
queue or not but
and if you're traveling good [ __ ]
luck i tell you there's a there's a
fight now every three days on airplanes
i i was traveling last weekend at the
gate announcement the guy was saying now
boarding welterweight to middleweight
members of the armed forces with ptsd
and
families beating small children it was
ridiculous
[Music]
but we are back on january 21st so
that's a
well thank you
are you applauding the two months we're
off or that we're coming back
but i'm gonna that's a lot of time but i
am gonna need all that time to get
through the new uh taylor swift song
it's
this is
all america seems to be talking about i
don't follow her that cl as closely as i
should i remember she went out with jake
gyllenhaal
like 10 years ago right and now i hear
she's got this 10-minute song about how
he did her wrong and i'm like
he did it again
am i
no she
it's the same from wow i thought
republicans were stuck in the past
but
but it is it can't deny your popularity
it is shooting up the charts with a
bullet
the same one jake gyllenhaal dodged
now she's very upset about the nine-year
age difference that they had
really yes he was old enough to be her
father's stepson from another marriage
you know what you kids do a lot weirder
[ __ ] than that
how about shake it off
wow
but the uh big news today serious news
the verdict in the kyle rittenhouse
trial has come in
innocent he is uh i know if you don't
know the story he's a teenager
from illinois who traveled to wisconsin
because like all teenage boys he watches
too many comic book movies and thinks he
can be the avenger which is a bad
combination with guns
so today matt gates said he's innocent
he would like to hire him as an intern
well
that's true gates said he hadn't been
following the story too closely but he
heard cross state lines and teenager
president had a very big week joe biden
had a three hour long teleconference
with xi jinping the head of china and
i'm not sure for three hours joe was
fully engaged at the end the reporters
asked him how it went and he said uh
boring squid game is overrated
[Applause]
so uh
and but he got his big wish he signed
the big infrastructure bill yes
this week
and then of course
you know it's nice to see we're kind of
back to normal in the sense that we have
an infrastructure bill which was
important and now the president's doing
what president always did he's going on
the road to sell the thing right that's
what you do sell the people on that
first stop he's going right after the
signing one of the most structurally
deficient bridges in america in the town
of woodstock new hampshire oh my god and
it was a little dangerous because this
thing has been around for almost a
century and could collapse at any time
and the bridge is in bad shape too
you